nous refusons de participer à ce qui est
un déshonneur pour l'assemblée nous
devons respecter notre construction dans
ces conditions la majorité
présidentielle refuse de continuer à
participer à ces débats qui ne sont
qu'une mascarade
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
durant les 25 dernières années cette
assemblée n'a cessé d'adopter des textes
ayant méthodiquement détruit et
démantelé ce qui faisait notre fierté
nationale
un service public unifié de l'énergie
qui procurerait à la France
l'électricité la moins chère d'Europe
cette œuvre de destruction a aujourd'hui
des conséquences directes directes sur
nos commerçants et nos artisans que nous
proposez-vous monsieur le rapporteur une
proposition de loi juridiquement bancale
au minimum
inutile mais sans doute pire
contre-productive parce qu'elle va à
rebours des objectifs que nous portons
pour l'avenir d'EDF c'est la première
fois
à moins qu'on me démontre le contraire
sous la Cinquième République un texte va
être voté en l'absence de la majorité
vous symbolisez monsieur le ministre
seul à votre banque une symbolique
politique qui est désormais irréfragable
le gouvernement est seul seul contre
tous
devant son incapacité à faire face à la
crise énergétique et devant ces
velléités imposées au peuple français
des décisions contre son intérêt la
vérité c'est que vous ne voulez pas
assumer vos votes et vous ne voulez pas
affûter le refus de cet article sur les
tarifs réglementés parce que vous savez
qu'on en a besoin voici le résultat du
scrutin votant 210 s'exprimer de 106
majorité 104 pour
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]